hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sport
take it away Wade alright guys in the
last one we we moved around without any
legs we're giving ourselves some legs
[Music]
bunk I feel like our mouth is less
effective now no no it's good not in it
oh my god there we go too grandiose here
it's pretty intense it's it's not bad
it's not bad it's it's pretty good but
we have more space for the nipples to
shoot out now I think that's what he was
missing much better right in front of me
[Laughter]
we're gonna spend five minutes on this
is the chain probably move now compared
to the last ball we can move but do we
[Music]
oh that's right they're moving to a
bigger nest oh that one I that's my
grades a new nest we follow them to find
a mate and claim a new home base do it
let's check sorry I forgot I was in
control of the mouse that's normal hey
jump man
[Music]
[Applause]
you kill them okay why are we go there's
a lot of it's a giant cricket oh
goodness oh they'll come after us
of course it's coming after us we're
leading it to our nest oh well we need
to go that way where are we going we're
going right there okay quick quick God
oh well we're here about to become
extinct of the giant grass
oh I was right that we were getting too
grandiose there that's very right I did
not realize how right I was
mates make a baby goddamn bang me
scrapping and starting from oh we lost
our vision there's the grasshopper no no
no no no stop twitching everything
everything's going everything is awesome
you're gonna shrink back wait no you're
gonna shrink back drink back shrink
shrink shrink we're starting from fresh
remember simplicity is key you can have
a lot of parts but all this all this all
this all this too much too much okay
okay dignified we can mate right away
how does
[Music]
the mouth of the alien creatures just
like on its own
I just saw the underside of his jaw it
was like some texture that I got it it's
like it turned in by trips to phobia I
get so triggered look at that Oh Tripta
faux pas
I'm tumblr triggered oh let's not do
this and do anything but this we got a
hundred and ten left oh you have an ID
ideas any ideas of what we should do we
could put different video minute you
want the web Wilders yes of course we
want the web models and let's if we need
some these weapons we definitely some
more weapons weapons of course another
set of legs what's the purpose and
weapons oh my god yes beautiful you're a
genius
Wow oh you're the who you're brilliant
and
where the stumble still scope mother in
there somewhere
okay alright wow we have so much Kreutz
force a corrosive sake good old
corrosive sick I love it it's beautiful
earth it's very elegant in everywhere
skin my mom I like your testicle
delightful purse
- god damn it oh God Oh at least we can
dance that's what's important what are
the bulbous things on the back of our
back feet we are invincible or blazing
we have so much health we do so much
damage this is amazing oh we are a
deadly force oh hello wanna die weirdo
hey don't look at our but we're in
social stances become bat sense to stuff
alright three you paused it oops
extinct them all yeah oh wait no we can
recruit our friends what are we doing go
back home go back home were supposed to
do this run you're dragging that huge
testicle well done teammates
well done fan thanks looks so happy
about everything they're doing
beautiful beautiful on the Alpha
CrossFit a is on our face on our team
our team not on our face of course
croctopus' wow that is ok we're fighting
now apparently don't don't let it kill
you wow that is terrifying
we will become the alpha now yeah but we
got one of them will come back you know
know me as I slam my testicle in the
gram of my mating dance we didn't know
we were really trying not to that
feeling laughing I'm scrapping
everything I'm starting over
Oh No yes I'm starting over cuz this is
all gone horribly wrong it's distracted
from my vision I don't like that's not
good
[Laughter]
we have the same skin
[Music]
[Laughter]
afraid of me I don't know what we're
running into thank you so much for
watching we're actually losing daylight
so that's why we're getting darker here
this is a thing of beauty I don't know
what weights bitching about over there
but I think it's beautiful so thank you
everybody so much for watching we may
not have time to record another episode
which may mean that spore will be over
for a while we'll see how we stand and
as always we will see you in the next
video and then there was a war and
everyone guy
[Music]
they're like nerds nice belts on your
hat we're all let's get four you don't
think we're going to get along
oh no we're starving